there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home he is not attempting
to critique everybody he's only
critiquing a certain radical subsection
as opposed to you know the people who
actually destroyed his presidency at
every point george w bush goes to the 9
11 memorial in shanksville
and he proceeds to say some very very
nice things and then he says one thing
that ends up being the headline of
course because he was trying to say
something unifying and um he failed so
he starts off by talking about how
americans when we are forced together
are exceptional which of course is true
20 years ago terrorists chose a random
group of americans on a routine
flight to be collateral damage in a
spectacular act of terror
the 33 passengers and seven crew of
flight 93
could have been any group of citizens
selected by fate
in a sense
they stood in for us all
the terrorists soon discovered that a
random group of americans is an
exceptional group of people
facing an impossible circumstance
they comforted their loved ones by phone
braced each other for action
and defeated the designs of evil
okay and all of that was true and this
is the world that george w bush i think
wishes to occupy frankly it's a world i
wish to occupy as well i mean i i think
that what happened on flight 93 is a
great indicator of what americans are
when put to the test george w bush
continued along these lines and he
talked a little bit about the men and
women who have served in harm's way and
you start to see the first inklings here
of why the bush presidency which again i
think that bush in many ways is a man of
principle but the bush presidency was a
disappointing failure in many ways and i
think one of the reasons was because
again he he just did not defend his own
policies he did not defend what he was
doing so here he was it's 20 years later
we've now surrendered in afghanistan to
the very people who perpetrated 9 11.
and george w bush has had not a word to
say about that really he said not one
word about the policy he's he sat aside
well
joe biden surrendered the entire country
back to the exact people who did 9 11. i
mean like the exact people who did 9 11.
he had nothing to say about that instead
he has sort of comforting words for the
for the members of the military which is
fine but where is he when it comes to
the actual serious questions of policy
let me speak directly to veterans and
people in uniform
the cause you pursued at the call of
duty is the noblest america has to offer
you have shielded your fellow citizens
from danger
you have defended the beliefs of your
country
and advanced the rights of the
downtrodden
you have been the face of hope
and mercy in dark places
you have been a force for good in the
world
nothing that has followed
nothing
can tarnish your honor
or diminish your accomplishments
to you and to the honored dead
our country is forever grateful
has a rather oblique critique of the
biden foreign policy in afghanistan okay
so if you're gonna do a unity speech
then what you really need to talk about
are unifying principles right you need
to talk about what brings america
together and george will be bush did
many of those things
in that speech
but if you are going to critique then
the critique has to be pointed and it
has to be specific
or at least it has to be broad enough to
encompass the big problems in american
society
people on the right i think responded
with the trump era because of the obama
year but also because of the bush here
as we'll see in just one second because
here is george w bush this is the clip
that made all the headlines right it
wasn't all of the talk about unity it
wasn't all the talk about bringing
americans together
it was this line from george w bush that
brought all the commentary this is the
line where he compares the january 6th
rioters to the 911 hijackers
we have seen growing evidence that the
dangers to our country can come not only
across borders
but from violence that gathers within
there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home
but in their disdainful pluralism
in their disregard for human life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
okay so everybody took this as a
critique of the
one-sixth writers
now it's possible to read it as a
broader critique than that right that
he's talking about white supremacists or
that he's talking about antifa or that
he's talking about black lives matter
the problem is of course that he
released a statement in favor of black
lives matter last june
in which he talked about systemic
american racism and all the rest of the
left-wing buzzwords and it is also
possible to say that the 1-6 rioters did
something evil i have said that
many many times i think that storming
the capitol building on the basis of a
falsehood
both that the election was stolen and
that the election results were capable
of being overturned after having been
certified at the state level that was
all a lie that was not true and they
stormed the capitol building
to compare those people still to the 9
11 hijackers who literally murdered 3
000 americans the only american who was
actually killed at the capitol on one
six like died at the capitol on one six
because of direct action by another
human being the only person who actually
died because of that was ashley babbitt
right who was shot at the capitol and
she was one of the rioters
okay that that is not remotely the same
thing as the 911 hijackers
either in their aims i mean the goal of
the 9 11 hijackers was to completely
overthrow the the system of the united
states not because of a quote unquote
stolen election or anything like that
but because they didn't believe in
elections they believe in full-on sharia
law right they wanted the kind of
governance that you see in afghanistan
the comparison fails on nearly every
level but what's more important is i
think george w bush thought that he was
saying something unifying here right
which is that attacks on american
institutions and attacks on american
principles are unacceptable across the
board but the feeling that people get on
the right is that he doesn't mean it
across the board and by the way that was
the feeling on the left as well because
if the left thought that he meant that
across the board if they thought that he
equally meant the 1 6 rioters and the
people who burned down american cities
last summer resulting in at least
five billion dollars in property damage
about two billion dollars of insured
they that if they felt that he was
applying that to antifa with the same
sort of alacrity that he was applying
that to white supremacists
then there might be some sort of unity
but they don't feel like that and
neither is the left and the reason you
can tell the left doesn't feel like that
is because they were giving him the
strange new respect treatment and this
is what's truly going after eight years
of defending george w bush in his
policies
after eight years of going to political
battle
for the bush administration on behalf of
many of their policies right i disagreed
with george w bush a lot and sometimes
i'd critique him but if you go back and
read my columns i was i defended many of
george w bush's big moves when he
wouldn't defend himself
after eight years of that to feel as
though the ex-president of the united
states who you defended only emerges to
critique one side of the political aisle
even if that side deserves critique even
if those radicals deserve critique but
he is not attempting to critique
everybody he's only critiquing a certain
group
a certain radical subsection of a
movement as opposed to you know the
people who actually destroyed his
presidency at every point
and then to receive the strange respect
from the same people who spent eight
years declaring him a warmonger and a
bad human being that's how you get trump
that's how you get trump and you deserve
trump
right that's how it comes to that
and you can see the left celebrating
bush right you have joe biden who says
that you know bush made a great speech
about who we are why do you think joe
biden is celebrating george w bush
he spent years ripping on george w bush
in 2008 when biden was running alongside
barack obama he labeled john mccain a
continuation of the horrible the
horrific bush era that was the main line
george lily bush was so bad and john
mccain will be more of that
i mean joe biden spent years trashing
george w bush but now he's very happy
with george w bush which makes you think
has joe biden changed or
is george w bush just paying homage to a
delusional conciliation that does not
exist in american politics here is
here's joe biden
i thought that president bush made a
really good speech today
genuinely good speech
about who we are where we're not
the core of who we are
is not divided
the core of who we are is not divided
says
this is the part where again
i think bush is misreading the situation
and i think a lot of the right-wing
establishment the con so-called this
conservative establishment is misreading
the moment
i'll explain more of this in just one
second because
when joe biden said
that he was trying to generate unity
when he was inaugurated i said at the
time
we still have to define what he means by
unity by unity does he mean they're
going to attempt to come together around
common principles and leave people alone
let them live their lives or by unity
does he mean you shut the hell up and i
will tell you what to do and it is
extremely obvious at this point that joe
biden means the latter and if george w
bush means the former then unity does
not mean the same thing to george w bush
that it means to joe biden
and yet george w bush is using the exact
same language which is a dangerous thing
to do it obscures clarity it makes
things opaque and not only that it
grants weapons to the people who
actually wish to infringe upon your
freedoms each and every day and divide
americans each and every day
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang